my name is uh
alex thomas thanks you don't applaud yet
you haven't seen it so
um you just like it thank you
um yeah so my name is alex uh i'm the
currently cto of artemis internet
uh i was one of the co-founders of
chemical license partners uh artemis is
a sister company isec doing some r d
stuff
i've spent my entire career uh working
basically to protect global capitalism
against people who are trying to break
into it right so i'm a
what you would consider an infosec sell
out in the information security industry
a white hat
a professional hacker on side of the
good guys before
i started i sec i worked at a company
called at stake
which was a company known for having
better technical people than financial
sense
before that i was in charge of security
company called loud cloud
which is mostly famous for ending the
first.com boom
um with our six dollar ipo and thirty
dollar stock options
so uh and before that i was at the uh
small uh public school for poor kids
across the bay
where i got to work with dave patterson
and dave wagner and some fantastic guys
i got to meet john hennessy and there's
a story about being in the woods with
him
that i can't tell on video but anyway uh
today's talk is about snowden so uh you
know everybody in this room is perfectly
qualified to understand
the snowden uh disclosures i think where
i'm going to try to add some benefit for
you as i work in the corporate world
on a day-to-day basis we work with all
the largest internet companies
most of the largest banks in the country
um several international institutions
that are really worried about this kind
of stuff
in fact this talk i put together this
wasn't
although i have some political uh
interest in talking about this kind of
stuff
this was actually a request of um eight
of the truly too big to fail banks
things called the financial market
utilities
uh which are the people who actually
make all the money move around the world
uh generally if you google their names
you'll find lots of black helicopter
kind of
new world order theories about them and
they're terrified about this kind of
stuff because those are companies that
have to operate in lots of those
companies have to operate in lots of
countries with very aggressive national
security apparatus
and they have to maintain trust across
everybody no matter whether or not
they're considered an enemy or a friend
of any of those countries
um and so they asked what's going on
with snowden what should we do to
protect about it i put this talk
together originally for them
and they've given it several times this
will be the the first time it goes on
youtube
um so we'll see uh whether or not you're
watching me douse myself in fire and
set my career on fire that's my seven
gasoline
um so technically uh here's a warning
for anybody who has a
security clearance um these technically
the i have a bunch of the slides that
snowden have released and they haven't
technically been declassified right so
if you have a security clearance you
have a
duty of care for classified material so
in theory
uh you're not supposed to look at the
slide deck
i had i was required to put this in my i
gave this talk to a private audience of
which are about 100 people
with uh classifications in the audience
including a couple guys in
bdu sitting in the front seats um nobody
left when i said this but
i was asked to give this warning okay so
why should you care about the snowden
stuff
so internet service is one of the things
the united states still does really well
right uh we're not the world's leading
exporter of steel we're not the world's
leading maker of aluminum
uh lots of people make cars really well
that the germans believe that they're
pretty good as do the japanese
you can buy fantastic gas turbines from
rolls royce you can buy commercial
airline
airliners from airbus there are very few
things in which the united states is a
totally dominant exporter and one of the
last
vestiges of that is software internet
services and networking equipment
right so if you're just an american you
don't even care about the tech industry
individually but you care about our
economy and the long-term
uh prospects for the united states
competitively in the 21st century
um then i think you have to care about
the snowden revelations because it's
having a real impact
um to maintain this competitiveness with
the rest of the world we have to
maintain trust
um a lot of people are willing to buy
products from cisco and juniper
and they're willing to use yahoo and
google and salesforce because they
implicitly trust those companies
and they trust they operate in a legal
framework that has a
that provides a balancing act between
the needs of the state the needs of
individuals and the needs of those
corporations
right and it's that high trust society
that we live in
that has been one of the cause one are
one of the greatest economic booms in
the us history after world war ii it's
that high trust that people believe the
legal system is there
that it protects you that the rules are
followed that is why people invest in
the us and they use our products
and there's lots of already scary
numbers about what's happened since then
um there's an organization that's
estimating a 22 billion to 35 billion
dollar hit
to cloud computing providers over the
next three years um and cisco is already
blaming missing their
their quarter one numbers on the fact
that their sales in china dropped 20
percent
in one month after the snowy revolutions
turns out if you're in china not buying
cisco equipment it's actually a pretty
smart move
um associated with the executive who's
covering this
i haven't um read those comments no
i mean i i i'm sure you could interpret
multiple ways but i i have no doubt uh
certainly things have been expressed to
me personally about
people holding off on buying stuff until
they figure out what you know how to
handle this kind of stuff
um now even if you don't care about the
nsa as a threat actor to yourself
these revelations are really interesting
because they they finally provide us
with a good
level to know what the capabilities are
for major nation state actors
right so the the the last best look we
got at that was in 2009 with the chinese
with the aurora attack
which was a very small slice of the
capability now we know what
capabilities you have with physical
access what kind of cryptographic
capabilities are out there
what kind of storage capabilities and so
even if you're not worried about the us
if you have any nation state that is
possibly a threat actor against you
then this information is very useful i
also have this theory
of trickle down cyber warfare that we
can look at the current state
of threat actors who are not nation
states
and we can predict we could have
predicted where they were right now by
looking back in the past
so like i said 2009 the aurora attacks i
was involved 35 american companies were
hit by the chinese
using oday malware sent to an individual
inside the company
attacks against active directory using
both cryptographic and ode means
horizontal movement across the corporate
network and then the takeover of
individual laptops of key employees
that kind of technique technology in
2009 was only starting to get widespread
this is actually an attack technique
people call apt now
that the chinese got really good at in
the early 2000s
through a number of attacks against
defense contractors in the u.s
government directly
if you look today what the chinese were
able to do in 2009
any eastern european gainster and a
track suit can now do
right because you can hire a 17 year old
with a laptop and they can pull these
exploits off of an exploit market or
even existing apt software
repackage it a little bit and it still
works perhaps not in as hardened targets
like in north of grumman or lockheed but
in the in the normal standard fortune
500 company
they're still toast against the kind of
exploits that we've seen for six months
to a year
and so if we look right now what the nsa
can do perhaps we'll have a prediction
of what is possible for normal people to
do four or five years from now
for example the chinese were doing a lot
of ntlm2 cracking which in 2009 was a
reasonably
expensive thing right now anybody in
here who has a reasonably good gaming pc
can do the same level of ntlm2 cracking
the chinese could do in 2009
with a supercomputer ntlm2 is the
password-based authentication on windows
networks when you're not doing kerberos
and it turns out even if you're doing
kerberos you can make windows machines
speak ntlmv2
which is something that was used to
great extent by the chinese during those
attacks
also a reason to do this is that the
flame attack uh has taught me to say
never say never
uh the uh who here has heard of flame
um so flames generally considered the
the successor to stuxnet although
there's a lot of
evidence that flame existed before
stuxnet existed
and one of the interesting facts about
flame is it uses a certificate that was
stolen from microsoft using the md5
collision attack
against the public certificate authority
that was hanging out on the internet
and that certificate was then used to
attack windows update uh so it turns out
i actually ran the project in 2004
to do the top to bottom security review
of what is now microsoft update of the
the update service and soap protocol and
we had that exact attack
in our written report and we said
well this could happen this could happen
but don't worry it's totally impossible
right and so between 2004 and 2009 it
became
doable by at least a nation-state
attacker
and so you know it's things that seem
kind of incredible right now might not
be so incredible to us in four or five
years and i think the snowden stuff
again gives us a good predictive ability
there i mean even if you don't care
about the stuff
your customers do i'll just make it
clear you know this deck's meant for uh
businesses so i didn't create kind of an
academic dick for academics
you're all businesses right everybody
here has a startup right yeah uh every
19 year old
let a thousand startups bloom right in
the dorm rooms um
my you know my goal here was to speak to
as as if you guys are working at a big
multinational
bank um so you can kind of get a feel of
what they're concerned about and what
we're telling them
so um so there's some problems with
analyzing this known
disclosures one it's very difficult to
trust his direct assertions
for example he very famously said that
he had direct access to google servers
now what it seems to be now that we have
the the raw evidence
that he was talking about a level of
access that existed but he perhaps did
not know how that level of access was
given
granted to him um and so it's it's
either a misinterpretation or he
misspoke or we're just looking at one
tiny little part of a huge edited
interview but for the most part i think
it's very difficult to listen to
snowden's direct claims
and make analysis of it um so we're only
using documents that have been published
by the media that look like they're not
faked now it's obviously impossible to
authenticate any of this stuff
but there i've not seen any good claims
that things that come out from the
washington post or der spiegel
or el globo which apparently is
portuguese for el
the globo um the any of those
organizations are faking this stuff um
so we're just going to assume that
they're accurate
um the other problem is that we have a
lot of media filter problem with with
all this stuff
um either these documents are being well
one
the stories that are being written are
about political impacts right so you'll
read in der spiegel about
angela merkel's cell phone being
listened to being eavesdropped on
but how did they do that did they do
that by breaking a five slash one
on the gsm and passively sniffing did
they do it with an mz catcher and
building a fake gsm base station on top
of the us embassy
did they do it by implanting software
into her in
uh into the um the base band did they do
it by implant software into the
the os core of her phone all those are
practical
reasonable explanations of how that
happened but the dare spiegel article
doesn't talk about it because they don't
really care about the technical
side they care about the interesting
political impact um and so because of
that
decisions that are being made by the
reporters it's actually very difficult
for us on the defense side
to figure out what to do um so what
we're trying to do is basically read
between the lines of the informations it
published
i mean often what you'll see is you'll
see a washington post article that has a
slide deck
in their slideshow and most people on
the technical side we just ignore the
washington post article
and we go straight to the slide deck and
there's something that slide that's much
more interesting
than whatever the political impact of
this person got spied on or this kind of
information
that you're able to read between the
lines and figure out how technically
this stuff works
okay so my format today is i'm going to
talk about some of the revelations that
have come out
uh over the last several months uh
provide the supporting documentation
and we'll talk through that real quick a
little bit of analysis of what that
actually means
um and then suggestions if you're an
international business and you want to
counteract this kind of stuff what you
should do about it
and then we'll have we should happily
have 10 15 minutes of q a at the end so
if you have a question feel free throw
it out but let's not get into any kind
of political discussions or anything
uh like that until the cameras are
turned off um
so revelation the thing that kicked this
all off um is the the original prism
revelation which turns out to be like
the least interesting of all of them in
my opinion
which is the nsa has some kind of
automated mechanism to request
and get stored data that's currently
stored by major cloud providers
um this is well described in what a lot
of people are calling the world's
ugliest powerpoint
deck as well as a massive violation of
copyright law by including all of those
logos in there that's a big no-no this
is a list of providers that they're able
to get this data from as well as a list
of what you get
there's a good slide that shows what how
this collection actually happens and
what you see here
is that the data providers are talking
to the fbi not the nsa right and so if
you were yahoo or google
and you got one of these requests you
get the request from the fbi under
either
a fisa warrant a national security
letter an faa 702 order
and then you turn that data over the fbi
the fbi gives it the nsa
and then prism is really less about that
collection and more about
the internal analysis uh pipeline that
that data goes through and to correlate
and distort and all that kind of stuff
um this is where i thought actually the
slide deck started to get real
interesting where they talked about
prism versus
upstream collection so if you look at
here prism allows you access to
communications right so stuff that's on
hard drives in the data centers of these
companies
um and a number of different selectors a
selector
is a way to find out who's of to select
from your data set right
uh when you look at the nsa slides you
realize the nsa's problem is they have
too much data a lot of people have
talked about
anybody who's reading james banford's
books does not find that surprising
they're talking about petabytes and
petabytes of data finding the
interesting stuff is very difficult for
them so
they have a lot of focus on selectors of
finding ways to pull people out phone
numbers
email addresses fuzzy matches on names
a couple of slides talk a lot about how
uh you know for some of these names
it's actually have to be kind of fuzzy
because there's different anglizations
of arabic names and such
um and so what i find interesting here
first off direct
with the comps provider only through fbi
right so this kind of disproves the idea
that the nsa using prism at least is
directly working with these providers
the fbi normally handles this kind of
stuff anyway within the u.s
and then the upstream side i always
thought this would be much more
interesting there's no discussion again
in the stories about the upstream
components of these slides and we'll
talk about that in a second
um so if you read the prism stuff we're
really not
talking about direct access in like the
nsa can go and automatically pull this
data
um from that and from the slides we've
seen in my conversations with people who
work on this kind of stuff
um is that really prism is about having
a portal that allows these folks to
request data
in an automated fashion then have it
uploaded but that there should be a
human in the loop at these companies
that doesn't mean they always implement
it
but generally my understanding is at
these companies there's a human being
that looks at the request
judges it decides whether they're going
to fight it or not and then uploads it
this actually brings up a real
interesting problem for anybody who
operates a cloud an internet service
these days
which is dealing with the thousands of
different
uh law enforcement agencies around the
world i have a relative who works in
department like this at a major internet
company
uh and they get things like a faxed
request from a tiny
police department in germany saying this
is a
a legal warrant signed by a german judge
uh
in german uh requesting a gmail account
for for somebody who has kidnapped a
child and has asked for ransom
right um and so that's like a legitimate
request that has to be handled but how
do you authenticate that
over a facts and then make an
interpretation of the local laws and
whether or not it's a legitimate judge
that kind of thing's really difficult
um and so it seems that what prism is
about is bringing
all of those requests in the u.s for a
national security context together
into a central workflow where they can
be requested and handled and then upload
in a secure way so they're not doing
things like
printing up people's text messages and
then faxing them to the fbi or dropping
them in fedex or something like that
um it's likely a prism varies on a
provider basis
um and if you you know as i said the
slides demonstrate the data comes to the
fbi so if you're a company
and you get the request from the fbi
it's actually very tough to tell whether
or not that's an fbi thing or if it's a
three-letter agency thing
um so uh you know one of the important
takeaways here though from an analysis
perspective
is if you know the fbi comes to you and
says okay well
yeah we're not changing anything legally
we're not asking for anything untoward
but we're going to have you as part of
this program
that's going to sound really mysterious
but don't worry nobody will ever find
out about it
that perhaps you you should worry a
little bit and i think the ability for
these companies to participate in this
stuff in the future is going to be very
difficult
um so what do you do if you're a company
here this is mostly a legal issue it's
not a technical issue
um so uh you know if if you haven't to
this point at this point every major
provider in the world has now thought
about this
um but it's amazing how many companies
store data have not thought about the
legal
access issue they haven't thought about
the communications decency act dmca
kalia and all the different laws that
that govern the turnover of data
um and the fisa authorization act
obviously um turn over this data to law
enforcement
um so you need to think long and hard
about what different requests what kind
of process you're going to go through
and who authorizes that and what your
policy is going to be and it's good to
publish that policy
um and most of these companies if you
search for them their name and then you
search for like law enforcement policy
you'll find a pdf that they that they
give out to law enforcement saying this
is how you ask for data
and this is what we'll give you and this
is what you won't um and while that's
not supposed to normally be public
public they know it's going to leak and
it's nothing that secret and it's
actually
a very interesting read the f of a
section
uh 702 stuff is even more interesting
because that's like the
metadata request of verizon uh which
again is mostly a legal issue it's not a
technical issue
um but i think this is something has to
be taken care of
more democratically than anything else
um designing thinking that designing
ended in encryption is going to save you
against this obviously is not
if you look at the lava bit example
that's a company that was forced to go
out of business
because they were not able to they were
turning over only encrypted inboxes
because the encryption of that of those
mail boxes was happening in javascript
in the browsers
and so the government forced uh
eventually had a judge
try to force the owner of lavabit to
back door
that javascript to steal the password so
they could decrypt it offline
he refused to and instead of doing that
he actually shut down the entire company
there is a regulatory arbitrage
opportunity here and i would not be
shocked
if what we see is american companies
building data centers overseas putting
the data of people from those countries
and keeping them physically there
and then either using encryption or
controls to
maintain access to that only to
employees that are outside the reach of
the us government
and that's probably a survival mechanism
that we'll see from some of these folks
it's also disclosure for lawsuits
if data flows through the united states
it's open to discovery
right right and even without tlas
involved if you talk any of the lawyers
of these companies they say diverse
attorneys are the worst
for that um because almost anything is
relevant in divorce case
right and and so it turns out that a lot
of stuff there's a lot of interesting
law
about that that's been created by
divorces like for example the fast
tracks and such
there's all this interesting law around
tracking those because divorce attorneys
have figured out oh i think this
person's mistress is on the other side
of a bridge
therefore we're going to subpoena the
data records and so there's
or they're saying manhattan yeah exactly
um so uh the next interesting revelation
the thing that was the upstream side of
that slide
uh was that the nsa is actually doing
full-on sniffing and major points of
presence of the internet around the
world
hoovering up whatever data looks
interesting to them and then building a
analysis pipeline where that data gets
reduced and reduced and eventually gets
sent to a central location
where it gets stored um one of those
databases is called x keystore
and x keystore shows up in a lot of
different places here
this is one of the slides from that
original slide deck where they talk
about the difference between prism and
upstream
um and then fairview stormbrew blarney
and oakstar we know what some of those
are but not all of them but those are
mostly
things that then use the upstream
collectors to then
correlate data then figure out
interesting things about these targets
this is a good background from the nsa
of why this works which is
if you look at how undersea cables work
if you go to telegeography for example
they like to map how the physical
infrastructure the internet
what you'll see is that a huge amount of
the traffic between different continents
all flows through north america
it's basically impossible to get a
packet from south america to europe
without flowing through a u.s points of
presence
which uh you know has to do with history
and the companies that own it as well as
geography right it's a lot longer
trip to go across the the south atlantic
for example and not as much economic
benefit to do it perhaps that's going to
change a little bit
but as these guys talk about you can do
sniffing in the united states and catch
a huge amount of traffic that
you would not expect is actually flowing
physically through the u.s this is a fun
thing to test whenever you go travel i
went to buenos aires during this whole
thing
i did a bunch of trace routes to
european ip addresses um and i bounced
off of miami a lot it was a lot of fun
yes ma'am a lot cheaper to go asia
pacific
to us than to europe directly
um is it cheaper for companies or from
like a ttl perspective
um there's actually a lot of good
stories here that you hear
uh when crazy stuff happens with bgp
routing when you cut a fiberoptic cable
and such and you'll hear crazy stories
about how these
cables actually work um when i was at
loudcloud
somebody pulled a backhoe across a fiber
optic cable
in nebraska anybody know where all the
fiberoptic cables are buried across the
us
railroad tracks that's right if you
think about it you want to pull a cable
three thousand miles
you can either deal with a hundred
thousand farmers
and and buy their land on the way or you
can just call it you know southern
pacific
and then buy a six-inch strip of their
right-of-way
which was already granted them by
congress in like 1850 something
um and so that's how they lay these
cables that they have like a big train
where there's a
the front train digs a trench and then
they lay the conduit and then they lay
the cable and then they cover it over
and then they just pull it and so but a
lot of construction happens around these
you know people build train stations and
dig gas pipes and all that kind of stuff
somebody pulled a backhoe and cut like
four fiber optic cables all at once in
nebraska
and for a while the routing for loud
clouds east coast and west coast data
centers were hopping through europe and
asia
so there are fiber optic cables across
russia
but a lot of it is oceanic because it's
really hard to dig in siberia
right um so anyway tell geography is a
great place to read about this kind of
stuff
um this is the map that came out later
about all of these sniffing sites
um and so you can see uh the the biggest
ones here the blue
ones are ones that are the large cable
sniffing this is most likely the
sniffing that's being done
with uh uh with the cooperation of the
companies involved
um so a lot of the information we know
about this we actually knew in 2007
uh because a gentleman who worked at
eighteen t uh here at the folsom street
att
office uh blew the whistle and called
the eff
after he saw that there was a passive
fiber optic tap on a major
uh fiber optic line att that then went
into a classified room
where the nsa had racks and racks of
equipment i mean so there's a whole
lawsuit and such and the lawsuit was
squished by congress
exposed facto there's all this
interesting law around it um
but anyway that's the kind of sniffing
that cannot be done without the company
knowing
right we're not talking about tiny
little fiber optic taps here you're
talking about people sniffing
huge sonnet rings that do tear bits per
second across multiple dwdm colors
right and so realistically to sniff that
to demultiplex it
and then to look at in real time you're
gonna have to have racks and racks of
equipment you're gonna be pulling
tens or hundreds of kilowatts of power
right um so almost certainly
all those big blue ones are the places
where the nsa has made a deal
with the providers the companies that
have run it which also makes sense
because if you look at the blue ones
they're all in
companies they're all either in
countries that we're allies with or
they're on cables that are partially
owned by a u.s company
um then if you look at the smaller ones
you've got like the
the the yellow ones which are all
through china and the red ones
that seems much more likely to be
something that is not well known to the
the host country or the host company so
it's either gonna be a physical tap
somewhere in the middle of nowhere
that they've put in place or perhaps a
software tap i mean and since
this has come out we've learned about
the kind of software implants that the
nsa has for juniper and cisco routers
and such
so it is possible those are implants
that aren't doing sniffing all the time
that they're they're doing you know they
wouldn't be able to pull the entire you
know 10 gigabit
wan link or something like that but
maybe they can do some individual
looking at packets and pull it off of a
router in the middle of nowhere
my guess is this map has changed
significantly since it leaked um
uh this is the chart that came out of
the eff's lawsuit of how this uh
hookup works in the att office um what
was interesting was it was a passive
link so the nsa is not really
man in the middle of the situation
they're just passively listening to
traffic go back and forth
turns out this can be leveraged to
create a man-in-the-middle attack and
we'll talk about that
a little bit later part of the slide
deck talked about how useful it was just
to sniff hdp
because such a huge amount of traffic
goes over it this is kind of an
embarrassment to our industry
that we have this entire time had the
technology to keep this data
secure at least against a passive
sniffer attacker like the nsa but we
never really bothered to
um and a huge chunk of people's
day-to-day lives is already done
is done on totally unencrypted
connections um
here's an example of i believe this is
the x keystore database so it shows you
what the
the gui interface looks like a lot of
these slides are really blurry i think
this is actually
a screenshot of a tv show that then had
a camera pointed at a tv screen
where they had a screenshot that was put
into a powerpoint deck so
um this is part of that media filter
problem it's kind of difficult to get to
the details when we've gone through that
many levels
but from this you can kind of see what
ex key source is storing which it looks
like
billions and billions of pieces of email
that then can be searched on things like
headers and
what what's mentioned into it uh stuff
like that email addresses and such
um so our analysis here uh so it seems
that the nsa is using optical taps in
this case uh which an optical tap on
like an att back
uh bone connection is going to get you
not just public internet traffic
but it's going to get you all the phone
calls that are routed on sonnet on there
um mpls connections even dedicated
lambda we'll talk about that in a second
um the one of the reasons they're doing
this passive sniffing probably is
because it it prevents any leakage from
going to the carriers
right so the nsa certainly does not want
to ask at t
please give us the email from this
person right that's it's classified that
they're looking at that person
um or you know and only in some cases do
they want to ask for everything like in
the faa 702 warrant
that went to verizon to ask for the
entire metadata and so a passive sniff
allows nsa to pick and choose what they
want um without
with and it allows the the uh the owners
of these cables to kind of cover their
eyes and their ears and pretend that
they don't know anything's going on
they're like oh well the nsa said
they're only following the law but we
can't verify that because we're giving
them everything
it seems that almost all of the major
u.s and many overseas carriers are
implicated
most of the cables that run or i think
all the cables that run to and from
north america
are joint ventures between a us a
domestic and another company
often level three communications global
crossing um british telecom
att all those folks go into they create
these special companies that own the
cable
and then you have a joint venture to
build it there's a famous ntt and att
who do a lot of the ones to japan
um so it'd be interesting there's some
interesting political things here
whether or not the partners in these
joint ventures knew that one side of
their fiber optic cable was being tapped
i'm sure there's been lots of fun phone
calls uh in japanese
um but uh you know as you can see as we
saw that map there's collection points
all around the world
so we're probably also talking about
secret taps um which i would guess would
have much more limited capacity right if
uh
you know we we are the united states
already obviously has the ability to do
really cool
stuff like have submarines go and tap
fiber optic cables but we're not
dropping an entire data center
uh in a multi-megawatt power plant on
the bottom of the
the red sea right so it's likely that
that kind of stuff is much more limited
in scope um obviously essay can't record
everything uh so if you look at these
slides you see that there's a very steep
funnel
where they're trying to throw away the
stuff they don't want um
that turns out to be really easy right
because if you get rid of netflix and
youtube that's actually something like
of bandwidth in a number of different
backbone locations um
and so uh my guess is what they're
getting is like netflow analysis right
this ip talked to this ip at this time
emails perhaps the entire body at least
the to and from in the subject
headers um sms messages will be really
easy sms messages come as series 7
packets over the series 7 network which
is on the same fiber optic cable and
goes over sonet
those are completely unencrypted and my
guess is they're also trying to get dns
it turns out analyzing a dns record of
somebody gives you a huge amount of
knowledge into what they're doing on the
internet
this is a very useful thing to know as a
defender because if you want to set up
your organization to be able to deal
with a major breach like
google and those companies faced from
aurora then having logs of every dns
request from your corporate network
is super super powerful and likewise dns
requests are
nice small whatever 170 byte requests
they can press up real easily
just grabbing every single dns request
is not that hard um in fact i'm part of
this organization called dns owork
because we're doing a bunch of dns
analysis uh where you just pay five
grand and you sign an nda
and you get access what's called the day
in the life data which are snapshots of
three days of request to the root
servers um and three days of requested
all the root service is only about eight
terabytes right um
so that's you know obviously the amount
of data you can get out of that
spectacular for a very small amount of
storage
uh so what should you do about it so
clearly i mean the if if we're trying to
defend against passive attackers
sniffing all this data
that the the easiest hardest solution is
to move everything https it's
it's very easy for us in the security
industry to say i'll just do https it's
no problem
it turns out when you when you start to
look in production level sites
one some of these companies have on the
order of a hundred thousand front end
servers
doing http and ssl termination right so
on a level of hundreds of thousands of
cores anything that adds or subtracts 15
cpu power um i mean you're literally
talking about the amount of
energy dissipated by small towns right
that you're changing
from these companies i'm not joking
right the amount of power
that you're talking about and hardware
that you have to throw at is pretty
spectacular
um and so it is not totally cheap
uh to do that um but it is what we have
to do
and fortunately the ietf is moving this
way already
anybody here been following http 2.0
yeah
uh yeah so htv 2.0 is going to be a
standard that's probably coming out in
late 2014 early 2015 to replace http 1.1
that we've been living for a long time
http 2.0 the base was just a copy of the
speedy protocol
that google created speedy by default
does non-authenticated tls right so it
does kind of opportunistic tls with a
diffie-hellman handshake
you don't you're not required to use a
certificate so you don't have to have
verification of the server side
but that's good enough to prevent this
kind of white said sniffing
um and so speedy's you know not
supported by a lot of people obviously
google supports it
facebook uh supports it uh and a couple
other big companies
chrome and firefox support it but ie
doesn't but as soon as this becomes http
2.0
i would expect all the browsers all the
mobile operating systems
uh and all major providers will
eventually support it in which case
this kind of attack will become much
less useful by the nsa
another thing you should think about is
elliptic curve diffie-hellman ephemeral
uh perfect for secrecy
there are some interesting caveats on
the crypto stuff and i think i'll talk
about that a little bit later
um our recommendation to companies is
not to use pots
phone lines for any critical
conversations um
so uh there's nothing you can do uh
basically to
secure a conversation from one phone
line to another um if i was the nsa or
any other
national security apparatus around the
world i would be tapping into the fiber
optic cables that lead into major
conference providers
right and it actually turns out to be
five or six major companies that handle
like 80 percent
of the conference calls for the fortune
500 um and so if
you know just a couple of good taps and
you can grab all of those conference
calls
the real problem is going to be what to
do with that data whether or not you
have good enough
voice recognition do automatic
transcription that kind of stuff
pots i'm sorry plain old telephone
service so you pick up the phone you get
a dial tone that's called that's pots
i was gonna say analog but it's pretty
much not analog except the last
quarter mile between yeah landline yeah
um so if you so our recommendations to
big companies is to use voip over
voip trunking over vpn connections now
voip has all its own interesting
security problems
most corporate networks are insecure
enough that they have the voip phones
and the the
desktops and the laptops all in the same
broadcast domain um and in a situation
like that
just any laptop can then hit listen to
any internal phone call um
and there are standards for security for
voip but nobody uses them
um because it makes the phones not work
uh and so
um uh so there are ways you could do it
better but at least for if you're gonna
have a
critical conversation between executives
they really shouldn't be picking up the
normal phone they need to be doing it on
an internal network only
uh what else to do uh think a lot about
dns and namespace leakage so
if you look at the oarc records what
you'll see is that for most major
companies
you can look at their dns requests and
figure out all of their internal names
of their servers
because at some point they're leaking a
lot of those requests
so you need to think a lot if you're
going to use a non-uh
you know standard rooted dns namespace
internally or even if if not then
you're going to have leakage either from
the networks from improperly configured
dns resolvers
or by people taking laptops in and out
right
of the network um you should really
support smtp tls
so that's you know opportunistic
encryption of encryption of smtp flowing
between
mail exchangers it's simple to
enable it's not that simple to make it
work because there's a lot of different
standards about
what the certificate c name should look
like the different mail exchangers
interpret different smtp tls stuff
this is the kind of thing i think as an
industry we need to focus on the
interoperability and making sure that
this works
all over the place um another fun
revelation
uh so the nsa in doing this widespread
sniffing is not just sniffing the public
internet
they're sniffing all the private land
links before between companies
um anybody here worked at a carrier
before at an att or verizon or uunet
i see a lot of grey beards this is gotta
be u-net yeah how you doing sir
so if you work with those companies what
you find out is that
as a percentage of the bandwidth that's
been sold internet traffic is actually
a small fraction of what these companies
sell they make almost no money off
peering doing internet traffic it's
almost just a loss leader for
advertising
where they make their money is selling
pre-provisioned bandwidth in
a different couple of different products
out to companies to run their wan
links um so all of the major internet
providers are huge customers of this
it's because a long time ago they
figured out google's probably the first
people to move hard into this but
they've all followed facebook and yahoo
and ever all those guys
they've realized that if you want to
talk to google from brazil
it is absolutely the slowest way to do
it is from the internet
from brazil to the us what they should
do is terminate that
that connection in brazil and then route
the traffic
if the request has to be served in the
us you route it over a private link
because you get way more provisioned
bandwidth way better quality of service
if you're paying lots of money to these
companies to provide you private links
now think about these private links
people talk about we're getting a
private link we're getting a lease line
you know you call up uh level three and
you say i'm on a leased line
between minneapolis and chicago they
don't go and have a backhoe go pull a
you know a trench right what they're
going to do
is they're going to provision out
bandwidth in some way between most
likely using mpls which is a
for those who don't use it is a what's
called a layer one point or layer 2.5
protocol
which is really just a header that's put
in front of the ip header that that says
this is part of a connection that needs
to be routed in a special way
so they go and they pre-provision the
bandwidth and they do a bunch of quality
service settings
and so you're traveling over the same
fiber optic cables that carry internet
traffic
but you have a special header so that
level three doesn't let it
leave that kind of pre-provisioned link
and they they and if there's a bad
quality of service thing
they throw away the internet traffic
people's youtube and netflix first
and then you know you're paying them a
bunch of money so you you get a better
quality of service
um obviously that's if you're doing a
fiber optic tap
the nsa sees that traffic go right
across that fiber optic line just the
header in front of it
right and i'm sure they're highly
qualified to drop that header
and then parse that traffic and put into
their databases which we know they've
been doing
for the big big boys they're probably
buying dedicated lambda dedicated
bandwidth
actual colors on these links and it's
understood that companies like google
and such
will go to a global crossing and say hey
great you've got a cable to
to england we want to have dedicated
bandwidth on that
and so they have dedicated equipment
that then goes into dwdm
multiplexing equipment and then get sent
over but obviously if there is a fiber
optic tap
between you know downstream of that then
all of that gets
added up the same place and so if you
look through the slides
they talk about some of the targets
google swift
swift is one of the financial market
utilities i was talking about they
handle
most of the big transactions between
banks around the world where you're
moving just cash
they're headquartered in switzerland but
they have to operate everywhere so they
have
a very extensive land network across the
world um
a french mfa petrobos which is the
brazilian oil company
which is where this again this is a
slide that comes from brazilian tv
where they're talking about oh this is
all about terrorism but they're looking
at the oil company
um so uh this is a
from a relevant slide deck uh my
favorite slide ever written by anybody
uh which somebody the nsa had a lot of
fun uh yeah the smiley makes us
awesome i mean this is great you know
this actually makes me think
you shouldn't use vizio right like if
you could it's better just to draw
something like this and put a smiley
face on it
um and spice up your presentation um so
as this talks about
the the layout of the google network uh
which
um as you can see here so there's a
thing called the gfe which is a google
front end
and those are the the front server
that's the first place that you enter
google's property when you go and talk
to any google property
and basically the way google does is all
the gfes are identical
so pretty much all of google services
are available going through those gfes
they terminate the ssl connection they
look at what you're requesting oh you
want to talk to mail or you won't have
to search oh you won't talk to news
and then those gfes intelligently route
that request
now in plain text across google's
private network to whatever server
handles it
right so if you're an american and you
have a gmail account and you're
traveling
in brazil and you terminate a brazilian
gfe
but your mailbox is in the u.s then at
some point in that
path they say okay well you need to go
to a u.s gmail cluster
and so that gets routed over the
internal network um the result
being that all of that traffic between
their data centers
is unencrypted um over the internal
network and therefore if you're the nsa
and you're tapping those fiber optic
lines
you're able to get all that traffic and
parse it out
um yes
uh so uh there's an arg the question is
why does this
require fisa review um how is the nsa uh
justifying this
uh and there is uh at least in the decks
we have
uh where what they're saying is their
nsa is only doing this in links between
international data centers of these
companies
so uh what they're doing is they're
looking they're tapping like at the
fiber optic line
on the english on the side of england
and they're able to get all the traffic
between
the virginia data center and the london
data center but they're technically
trapping it in the uk
they're also saying that the majority of
the traffic
is is for foreign nationals and so the
collection of american data
is only incidental um so i saw actually
a great translation of what these
different words mean
um to the nsa um and the word incidental
means basically they're saying if 51
of it is is foreigners uh then they can
do it which makes sense because
something like
probably 70 of 80 of google's customers
are not americans
right so if you gather all of google's
data by definition
it's majority foreigners it just happens
to be you get every american
um but americans aren't more than 50
now there there is some data though that
we see that i think
means that they're actually tapping
within the us um but as uh my wife wants
me to clarify i don't actually have any
internal information here so you're not
hearing anything new
uh this is all interpretation and
looking at these slides but if you look
at some of the things they have like for
example
there's a big slide deck um that talks
about
uh reading yahoo's backup archives
um and so unless yahoo is doing full
archive backups overseas
um then to grab that data they would
have to be tapping
uh you know domestic cables too
do it for them or i mean gchq do it for
them yeah there's a lot of discussion in
these slides about the five
eyes which are basically the anglophone
company countries the us canada
the uk australia new zealand um are the
core group of
countries that all cooperate on this
kind of stuff um and so a lot of this
a lot of these folks are doing the
trapping of the data and then sharing
systems
um in fact i think our next our next
thing is all gchq
decks but they're talking about uh they
have a back-end connection to the nsa
for sharing data and that kind of stuff
um so anyway uh by this this is probably
where ed snowden gets his
i have direct access to google servers
because if you're doing this correctly
you're
eventually going to be able to gather up
almost all the data google
stores right they do entire replications
of data centers
so if a whole data center you know falls
into the earth or gets destroyed
they have all that data somewhere else
so at some point
all of the data is going to be backed up
over their their private land links this
has led to some blowback
this is a friend of mine named brandon
downey um
you know i'm not going to read this uh
but you can imagine um he was not very
happy about this
you know the context here is that uh
google's been on kind of defcon 2 ever
since 2009
um which you know the aurora attacks
were kind of a loss of innocence for the
tech industry
uh because there's always been an
interesting level of
you know a lot of people hacking these
companies and trying to break in and
such
um but in 2009 we really kind of
realized that several nation states
china russia
for example have full teams whose
dedicated job it is to break into these
companies
right and that's actually a pretty
terrifying thing when you think about
there's somebody whose job nine to five
they come into an office
and they're going to get a bonus if
they're able to read my email
right um that's you know that's not what
we normally in the security industry
think of we think of
talented amateurs people who are
probabilistically breaking the systems
perhaps people that want to make money
and do so the easiest way possible
that's a lot different than my full-time
job is to make your job harder
and so since 2009 google and all these
companies have invested a lot in the
security
they've done a lot of work to close
doors against these attackers and
they've done so with the help of the us
government
after 2009 nsa and fbi dni
all those folks got involved in giving
targeting
information about possible threat actors
overseas to these companies
have been working with suggestions and
such and so you know
you can imagine you've got brandon
downey and his friends
barring up the windows against the
zombies on the outside with the nsa and
fbi standing behind them saying good job
good job
and then rifling through the filing
cabinet right while they're while
they're while they're doing that work
and so it's
more than anything else this backbone
sniffing thing has caused a huge amount
of blowback
in the tech industry and a lot of anger
another reason people are angry
is there's been a lot of fighting over
what fisa means and all the legal
controls around it
and so on the front end the us
government has been requesting data from
tech companies
sometimes the tech companies appeal it
and they have a big legal fight
um but it turns out none of that matters
that was all kind of
a kabuki dance because on the back end
they're getting all that data anyway
so uh you know this is where people who
believe in the rule of law
really start to think this whole thing
breaks down if we're going to have laws
that authorize the government to pull
this data down
that's great um but those laws need to
actually be able to be fought over not
applied unilaterally by stealing this
data through the back door um so some
analysis here
um like you talked about the documents
generally reference gchq as a source
so a lot of these taps are probably
offshore and then provided through five
eyes you might be safe if your links are
only domestic
maybe not the documents describe
writing proprietary code for data so
it's not just
google's http requests it's things like
i talked about there's a whole
slide deck about uh all the work that
had to go into
yahoo's uh compressed email backup
format
and they wrote a whole set of parsers to
automatically parse and decompress it
and such
um so you know what they're doing
probably is they're capturing everything
minimizing layer
this is somewhat obvious now that we say
it now
and pls like i said doesn't provide you
with any extra security uh so what do
you do
so the natural solution here is you have
to encrypt all internal connections
again
just like saying just do htps this is
one of those fun things that's easy
for us to say in the security industry
it's a lot harder to do at scale there
are two kind of
options here one is wire speed vpn right
this means
having a box on that fiber optic cable
before it leaves your data center
encrypt all your traffic before it gets
to another physical site that you
control
now the downside here is those kinds of
machines are expensive buying a wire
speed vpn that runs at the speed that's
never going to break
and then you have to buy two of them
right in case it does break it's not
cheap
um they don't fail gracefully right so
uh as anybody who's running production
level network knows
when you start to do vpn of all your
traffic you end up with unrepeatable
errors
that are very difficult to debug um and
and vpn does not make that easier
um another problem is that uh if you
take all of your traffic and encapsulate
it
then it's completely opaque to the
carriers and the carriers can't do any
kind of routing or
um uh or uh quality of service
right uh because all they see is tcp
packets coming along
uh with with fully encrypted payloads
and so some of these companies are
actually having the level threes
uh and the global crossings and the mcis
and those kinds of folks do routing for
them
um and so if you do this you might have
to have some complicated separation
between
ip addresses and you have to do a lot of
thinking about ospf and whether or not
that routing happens how quality service
works and such
um the other option is do encryption
server to server to have dual
authenticated
encryption between the servers as they
talk to each other and then you still do
the unencrypted wan but doesn't matter
because nothing hits that
unencrypted um this requires support in
your software
uh which is not uh super easy right it's
this is easy if you write your own
software it's not super easy but it's
doable if you write your own software
it might be impossible if you don't
write your own software um it
requires the ability to push keys out to
all your servers uh it requires
um you know a whole kind of operational
framework to support that
um the benefit is if the wired speed vpn
these security security issues still
exists inside of your data center
where if you go server to server now
you're protected all the way up to
server so if you have a compromise of
the network stack
in your data center you're you're still
in reasonably good shape my expectation
is the wire speed vpn is the kind of
thing you do if you're a bank
or an insurance company or kind of an
old-school company where you're not
writing your own software
you're gonna have legacy products that
have unencrypted communication no matter
what you can't do anything about it
um trust me there's no way to make two
mainframes talk to each other securely
by changing the mainframes right you
can't get tls support into a kicks app
on a zos machine what you have to do is
put network equipment on the outside
of those devices and so that's what
you're going to do if you're those guys
if you're a google or somebody like that
you'll probably go more in the server to
server encryption because you have the
ability to change your own software
around it and handle it that way
cool another fun uh revelation um so the
nsa actually well we've been talking
about passive sniffing actually has the
ability to do active man the middle
attacks against target individuals
um one of the the context of one of
these revelations was around belgicon
com which is uh one of the telephone
providers in
uh belgium uh anybody know why you'd
want to target a cell phone provider in
belgium
is there it's where the eu is yes so if
you if you can read all this if you
listen to all the cell phone
calls in brussels you'll be able to
predict what the eu's gonna do in almost
any circumstance right so it's a great
place
to be able to do that um now apparently
belgiacom wasn't just turning the state
over the nsa which
totally makes sense uh if you're belgium
and you want to keep the economy from
having the eu in town
you're not going to go cooperate with
the u.s on this and so
what the nsa needed to do was take over
the machine of
administration technical workers of
system ins basically working inside of
belgium
and what they talked about two different
methods either hacking the routers in in
in place or doing what's called quantum
insert shots
um so the router hacking uh is pretty
basic
you break into a router you set a static
route and now you're able to intercept
some traffic
um and the goal here was to intercept a
totally
generic uh uh uh request for some
you know not important site but then
insert od malware into that response and
use it to take over their machine
right so instead of you know the way the
chinese did this is they spearfished
these employees they did they did uh
lots of investigation
these people are on social networks and
then they put together an email that was
very specifically targeted that person
where they thought they'd most likely
get them to click on a link and then
from there they took over the machine
but that creates a trail
right that email now lives in the email
server and when
during this investigation we found out
where those emails were coming from that
helped us figure out where the initial
point of infection is
the nsa knows that that's a weakness so
they want to find some kind of ephemeral
way
to take over somebody's connection and
seed malware onto the machine
so the router hacking is one way the
other way was what they call quantum
targeting so quantum seems to be a
system
that utilizes the fact that the nsa is
doing
passive sniffing but in very privileged
locations
um to then do an active man the middle
attack by inserting traffic
uh and and beating a pac the legitimate
packet to the customer
um to the user uh and so um
as it talks about here basically they
watch for a tcp sin
uh in a synack um they
observe this the synap and then they try
to send the first bit of the http
payload before the first legitimate hdp
packet happens um this is what that
looks like it's pretty it's a pretty
simple flow
right so it's just like tcp sequence
injection but they see the tcp sequence
number
because they're passively sniffing it
right so you don't have to guess the tcp
sequence number
you can just insert the traffic and as
long as you beat it you're okay
so unlike say like the chinese they're
not actually a man in the middle so this
is not a perfectly reliable
exploit technique cmic is the chinese
national network information center
these are the people who
operate the great firewall which has
been demonstrated to have active man the
middle capability not just filtering
capability
what are they inserting most likely it
looks like and there's some other
description of this
they're inserting a small javascript
include that javascript include comes
off of a server
that the nsa controls and it
asynchronously basically sends a request
from that request they're able to
fingerprint the browser
and then dynamically choose an exploit
kit send back an exploit take over that
browser
and then have it call home either over
the same connection over a different
connection probably a different
connection
it's actually difficult um to make those
kinds of exploits work in browsers
reliably over the same connection
they probably call home over a different
connection
oh it's all in the slide deck yeah no
but has this been observed
oh i don't think anybody i have not seen
like a a tcp dump or something of this
happening yeah
um in the slide deck they kind of
explain how it all works and how they
have the ability to dynamically choose
um uh payloads based upon okay it's
firefox this version
and they have java so we'll use a java
payload or they have flash or if it's
you know an old ie we'll just do an ie
payload something like that
um my guess is also doing this on dns uh
because if you have a double response
you know inserting something http screen
has a little bit of danger right you
could break the flow
um i'm actually also a little
wondering there's a little interesting
this is only come out a couple weeks ago
so initially i didn't think they were
doing tcp inserts i thought they were
just doing dns but now it's obvious
they're doing htp
i i would think this would cause a tcp
reset because you'd have
acts you'd have a double ack from two
different packets but apparently
these tcp stacks don't do it so anybody
here who's an
enterprising grad student who wants to
write a fun little paper going and
looking at the vulnerability of client
tcp stacks to getting
two different totally different uh tcp
payloads at the same sequence number
uh would be interesting because uh and
it'd be interesting to look at what kind
of logging happens
because then if if that gets logged in
some way people could log and look for
this kind of attack happening it sounds
like
a generous of what you accept right and
and and the reality is like you know
you've got the spec and then you've got
real life where
weird crap like this probably happens
all the time right um
i was looking because i thought it was
dns and it turns out you you often get
two request two responses to dns
requests
because you'll have weird things like a
resolver a caching resolver in the in
the middle
send to send requests out to multiple
sites or send a request out
time out send a new one but then get a
response you know within the with before
the timeouts over that kind of stuff so
yeah i mean i i would guess they're not
doing this anymore um
in this way uh so you know best
protection here uh
is again https everywhere uh we also
suggest hsts which is acp strict
transfer security
which is the mechanism to tell browsers
to cache the fact that you run under
https and not allow http
hpkp which allows you then to pin that
certificate to which certificate you're
using
in certificate transparency you know
synaptic is a us company
semantics u.s company yeah i actually
have got some more stuff about this
that's why i want certificate
transparency although nrc enough
semantics the company that's right now
holding back certificate transparency
um which is interesting um uh
so another interesting revelation that's
related to this is um
the nsa likes to unwrap tls connections
uh which is not shocking but apparently
they're good enough at it
that it's something that their analysts
can use on a regular basis
um this is a slide from gchq where this
shows gchq sniffing technology
that then talks back to the nsa to get
keys right so the ns
the gchq watches the traffic records it
locally and then they see what the
handshake's like and they go call up the
nsa through an enterprise service bus
and they say hey do you have the private
key for this certificate
and then the nsa responds says here's
the private key and then gchq can go
decrypt that traffic locally um
what's interesting here is if you look
over here long haul is that the code
name of whatever is doing it
uh pairing encrypt attacks attaches
something called hpc resources
anyone guess what hpc means there
performance
computing right so they are doing
something that has to do with
uh doing big computer stuff it's not
just stolen keys
um this is what that interface looks
like if you want to if you want to uh
go look for this stuff again this is a
screenshot uh from i think brazilian tv
again
um if you want to go look up and try to
find a private key for like an ip
address
you can go query it and they'll give it
to you um
sorry query this is a database nsa runs
called flying pig
so
right yeah so they say okay great you're
talking to mail.stanford.edu
oh i wonder if we already have the
private key for that and then they go in
here and says yep here's the private key
you go load in your software and it goes
decrypts the traffic
i can't do that you can't do that no no
turns out although if there's budget
cuts you know who knows maybe this will
be a software as a service
um no no this is an internal uh nsa
uh interface so far yeah
um so a quick analysis of this um
there's no
indication of magic abilities like any
kind of really interesting cryptographic
breakthroughs
but obviously cryptanalysis is being
used because of the hpc
the hyperforce computing um what it
looks like they're doing is they're
saying great there's only x sites in the
world we care about
so let's put a huge amount of effort in
getting the private keys of those x
sites
and then we can use that over and over
again right so if you just set up a
random https site it's unlikely the nsa
is going to
care enough to get your key but if you
are you know
a message board that terrorists like to
use or if you're google
or facebook then they're going to care
enough to spend some time
and they're either doing that by
exploiting the front end system and
stealing the key
or by doing something encrypt analysis
um you know rsa 1024
uh it's been calculated multiple times a
lot of people have demonstrated that if
you have enough money in like the 50 100
million dollar range
then attacking it is totally reasonable
and that's especially true in this
circumstance
where you can record all this traffic go
attack it asynchronously
and then go use that private key to go
decrypt it assuming perfect forward
secrecy is not being used
um i i bet it's this other one this one
too
right all this is a again like a failure
of our industry kind of overall
is the way we do this is we create
front-end machines or load balancers
we have hundreds or thousands of them
and every single one of them has a copy
of the private key
right so they're like the most exposed
least protected systems
and they've got the piece of data one of
the pieces of data we care the most
about
um and so my expectation is that over
the next couple decades
we're going to change the way we do this
so that we remote
that handshake into a much more
protected infrastructure
or we're going to use hsm uh components
to protect those keys
um so what you do uh consider using hsm
so if you're a small enough organization
then it's it's you're not with a hundred
thousand but with a couple dozen
machines
it's practical to have hardware security
modules hold these keys
so that if those servers are broken into
they can force them to do unwrapping
live but they can't pull that key out um
we recommend perfect for it secrecy on
all tls um
if you're going to do perfect for
secrecy you have to do elliptic curve
diffie-hellman
um my summer talk uh this summer was all
about
interesting breakthroughs in the
discrete log problem which dan boney uh
was nice enough to uh turn us on to um
and that there's some interesting stuff
going on
in that area of mathematics that might
show uh you know
diffie-hellman over prime fields being
insecure within the next several
years um so you know uh the way tls
works
is the diffie-hellman exchange for
perfect word secrecy actually happens in
plain text
so you'll have a rsa handshake to
authenticate a server you'll generate
a secret and then you'll do a signed
iffy helmet exchange
but that's not encrypted by a symmetric
key so you can just do this yourself go
to google uh with perfect forward
secrecy
with a modern browser and then do a
wireshark and you can you can watch it
and you can watch the perfect for
secrecy handshake so if there's a
vulnerability in how perfect for secrecy
works it doesn't matter how good the
other crypto is
you can just get the secret key from
there and decrypt the the symmetric part
we recommend using hsts http to limit
the attack surface
right so if you use hsts then at least
people you're everybody coming to your
sites using https
if you use hpkp you can reduce that down
to only your certificate
that's owned right so this is the
semantic problem if you don't trust your
certificate authority
then you don't really have to with hpkp
you could tell
browsers that come to you only use the
certificate don't allow them to sign
something else
now again a bad certificate authority
attack can only work in an active
man-in-the-middle situation
we've seen that they can do that through
quantum insert but that's that's not as
widespread as this other kind of
sniffing
um but i would guess that the nsa has
been able to get american companies to
turn over
certificates to them um certainly
the civil authority system is totally
broken uh you look in your browser right
now you've got the turkish government
the chinese government the russian
government all have certificates in your
certificate
authority store um so honestly the u.s
is probably the least of your worries
there
and if you're a company that's
interested in this kind of stuff get
yourself on the
preload list so chrome has burned into
its code a list of these sites only use
https
and they only use these certificates so
right now if you go to twitter from
chrome
you actually will never try http and you
won't accept a random certificate
signed by scenic or the russians or
whatever uh with the twitter c name
you'll reject it because it's in the
hsts preload list uh which right now
there's no good standard for this you
have to actually
call a guy up at google and he puts you
in the list and then the firefox team
just
pulls that down into their repository
hopefully there'll be a more standard
way of doing this in the future
um if you want to trust certificate
authority then the only way really to
get that is to get them to implement
certificate transparency
which is an interesting protocol google
has gone standardized to basically
means that in a cryptographically secure
and a privacy enhancing way the secret
authorities publish a list
of an obfuscated list of all the
certificates they've ever given out
and so in a situation like that if a
civic authority gets a request from a
government
they can say okay sir here's a new cert
either i could put it in the certificate
transparency list and if anybody's
paying attention they're going to see i
just gave the cert out and that company
is going to say hey we didn't ask for it
and we're going to say i have no comment
and then they're going to know or we
don't put in a certain transparency list
and if a browser checks then it's going
to it's going to scream
and it's going to call home and tell
them that it's not a bad cert so
sorry the rfc isn't quite published yet
but it looks like it's going to be a two
yeah i mean it's
something draft status i mean ietf has
like nine levels of purgatory right so
i'm not i don't really understand which
level of purgatory it's in
um but it's uh but interesting enough
symantec is the company that's dragging
their feet the most to make this a
requirement
the most progressive company in this is
digicert so if you're going to buy a
certificate
right now i would recommend buying digi
certificate show vote with your feet
show that you care about certificate
transparency because they're going to be
publishing their ct log very soon
for all their certs you can pin the
certificates of privacy when you control
both sides so lots of companies build
mobile apps
no need to use a public certificate
authority you can just publish your own
certificate authority internally or you
can
burn that key in on both sides the
serial number
or i'm sorry the thumbprint of the key
so there's no need to trust anybody on
the outside
okay i'm gonna go a little faster sorry
um interesting revelation uh
nist back door to standard um so this is
uh there's a there's a thing that says
hey yeah we did a really good job we
backdoored a major cryptographic
standard in 2006.
um so they don't say which one it is but
almost certainly what it means is
um dual ec uh drbg it's not prng i have
a typo here
um this was a standard that nist
published as a requirement that you
would have to support
this pseudorand number generator it's a
deterministic pseudomember generator
that uses dual elliptic curve
cryptography at the time people were
like
why do we need this this is super slow
it's kind of crazy and complex
2007. uh dan shrumo and niels ferguson
from microsoft
uh gave uh one of my favorite crypto
talks i wasn't there but kind of
retroactively
a 15-minute rump session at crypto uh
with this fantastic slide
where they analyzed dual ec and they
said
um so what we're not saying is that this
thing has a back door in it
but if the magic numbers in this product
in this uh standard uh happen to be uh
points on a line on an elliptic curve
and uh then in that situation there is a
back door
and now we can go and predict um with
only 30 bytes of pseudorandom
uh of data from the the prng we can now
predict the entire infinite data stream
out of
it right um so i like how they're like
we're not saying there's a backdoor
but this thing's insane um what has come
out recently is then uh
has been known for a while is that uh
the rsa corporation publishes a
commercial library called be
safe that you can use in your product uh
so you can port secure
crypto they supported dual ec now that
by itself is not really that bad because
if you wanted to be fip certified you
had to have it in your suite
right you had to support it although
pretty much nobody's used it since the
2007 anybody who's been paying attention
has not used it um but what rsa did was
make it the default way pseudorandom
numbers were
generated so if somebody used the bsafe
library
um and they didn't really know what
they're doing which is kind of the
definition of using the be safe library
um then uh they would be using this
backdoor
serum number generator uh and reuters
has a story that i cannot confirm or
deny but reuters has reported that's
because the nsa
had a contract with rsa to do that for
10 million dollars
um uh which is a you know a small price
for your
reputation but um
you know help somebody make his quota
for one quarter right um
so i think this is actually probably the
most damaging of all the nsa revelations
one of the reasons is the whole world
operates on this standards right
so the reason why you can go to a german
website over hcps
is because until this point people have
trusted the us government to be an
honest broker
and setting cryptographic standards so
we can have interoperability around the
world
um aes sha-1 sha-2 the upcoming sha-3
standard
the most commonly used elliptic curve
curves
um and anything that has that's ever
sold the us government
implement the standards um so without
nist who do we trust and most likely
what's going to be is nisa
uh which is the eu's version of nist who
already is like super happy because now
people are going to have to read their
stuff they publish all this stuff that
nobody reads
and now they're going to be forced to
read and ease the documents
but this is going to be a huge pain for
anybody who makes software hardware
because you're now going to have
different standards for different parts
of the world
the russians already have a set of
standards called ghost that they require
people
to support and so likely we're gonna
have three or four i wouldn't be shocked
if the chinese have their own two
so if you're you're selling a router or
vpn device you might have to support
four totally incompatible sets of
ciphers um
which i'm not sure that how you run a
vpn between two offices in two different
continents
right i think one of the most
interesting things here is this kind of
demonstrates what
the nsa's requirements are back door are
so this was not a weakness this was a
real back door
right so there's a lot of talk about how
the nsa
reduced the effective key size of des
back in the 70s
from 56 bits to 40 bits and that that
was a weakness but that
in doing that they made dez weaker for
anybody around the world
right this was a back door that only the
people that generated those magic
numbers the first time
would be able to exploit um and so i
think that's interesting for looking
forward if you're afraid of that
then anything that has that kind of
requirement it can't just have a
weakness that's put into it it has to
have some kind of
super structured complicated backdoor um
which also hints for the strength of the
elliptic curve discrete log problem
right so uh you know ec ecc has only
existed for like 30 years
so we don't collectively you know the
the uh
discrete log problem across primes is
just for like 500 right like you're
using for maw's little theorem
and so we have 500 years of
mathematicians thinking about
uh prime numbers in this way but only 30
years of people looking at elliptic
curves um so a lot of people are worried
about it and like oh maybe there's an
absolute problem with liquid
cryptography but this points to not
because if the elliptic curve discrete
log problem is weak
then this back door could be exploited
by enemies of the nsa
so the nsa apparently does not have any
knowledge or they did not in 2007
that there's a basic weakness in ec dlp
which is great i think that's actually a
real positive outcome here
do other standards that come out of this
have a backdoor so aes
most people think probably not anything
in that kind of the way this metric
algorithm works a lot of people i've
talked to think
it'd be very hard to have something
there that's a straight-up backdoor it
would be a weakness that's exploitable
everywhere
shaw three maybe but probably not the
way the sha-3 protocol
hash was created was a pretty open
process and there's no real way for the
nsa to mix with it
the eccp curves maybe so the standard
ecc curves we all use
use curve parameters that were handed
down from the mountain
uh you know from mount maryland now
there is a document describing how those
curves were created
but um you know a lot of people are
wondering
it's like great we took this magic
number then we ran through a hash and
now we have a different magic number
and it's like that seems a little you
know there's a layer of observation
there but it seems like maybe a little
too
cute so um so what do you have to do for
this uh first you have to build your
systems with crypto agility
most systems are not built to be able to
change out the crypto algorithms very
easily so tls is a great example of
crypto agility
where you have different packages of
cypher suites that can be negotiated
dynamically
um you're gonna have to look for uh
supporting non-nist standard so the
ietf now has drafts in place to support
um three protocols that were invented by
dan bernstein um
a a elliptic curve uh signing an
algorithm
a a symmetric key and a a hash that's
based upon aes
chrome actually supports this already so
if you go right now
in the chrome dev version and you go to
youtube you'll see that you're using
dan bernstein's curves oh i'm sorry
you're using
dan bernstein's symmetric key and
signing algorithm and um
hash algorithm the curve can't be used
because you can't buy a certificate that
uses curve25519
from anywhere so it's a normal ecdsa
p256 curve
um but you know you're probably gonna
have to do that and get ready for a
nissa standards
um so in a related it turns out the nsa
has also inserted products in the back
door this is from the classified budget
that that was leaked of the nsa's black
budget uh where they're like this is why
we need so much money
we need this money to insert
vulnerabilities to commercial encryption
systems
um and complete enabling so enabling the
nsa term of art apparently for inserting
vulnerabilities into something
um a lot of people are trying to figure
out what corporation name fits exactly
into that gray box um
so uh my this is now this only came out
a couple weeks ago so i haven't had time
to do too much work on this
uh but the absolute most interesting
leak is the one that's just happened
this is think
this when i talk about the media filter
the media filters are starting to fall
down a little bit because now we've got
guys like jake applebaum who is a
security researcher
also wearing a journalist hat and he's
writing articles for der spiegel
but they're much more technical and
interesting technical side der spiegel
leaked
this uh 2007 catalog
of uh this is the the stuff you can buy
from the internal store at the nsa
of cool products that you can buy
internally and so this gives us a lot
more technical detail about their
capabilities it was yes this is like
yes jacob claus came and gave this to us
so if you look at here for example these
are implants which are
you know uh backdoor slash rootkit they
use the term implant
for multiple things that we would call
different things
and uh you know one here is for dell
servers so they're talking about the
ability to
to flash the the system management
module
on dell servers in a way that then even
if you wipe the os or change the bios
out the smm is able to come in
and repatch it for you um here are
physical
uh and firmware persistence on on cisco
equipment
um if you look you know close
um what you'll see arcstream is used to
reflash the bios and target machine
implant yada yada
implantation via interdiction so that
what we found out from this catalog
is that the nsa is interdicting
shipments so if you buy a cisco router
and you're an nsa target
they will grab that from ups or fedex or
whoever has it
and then modify it wrap it back up and
then let it on its merry way
um
uh i have not heard anything again this
is pretty new so i'm not i'm not sure
and there's
and i use ups as an example there's no
indication of exactly where the
introduction's happening so it could
happen
a lot of different places in the
logistical supply chain um
obviously if you're a big company you're
buying if you're iranian government you
buy 100 cisco routers you're not getting
them from ups right there's
there's a long supply chain there where
this interdiction can happen yes ma'am
has a
really long history of working with
companies and creating fake companies
yeah he hasn't been talked about a lot
in all of this stuff
yeah um i mean there's very ca is almost
mentioned nowhere here which is
interesting
maybe it's what what snowden had access
to this might be just a demonstration of
uh you know non-cooperation in the u.s
government where you know nsa is not
sharing its toys with the cia
cia's uh strengths is working with
companies yeah and it's quite possible
maybe the cia is doing the introduction
stuff i'm not sure
it's not clear from here this is really
just a technical catalog there's no data
here about what they don't come up with
an example they're just talking about
what they can do
um so uh when we say backdoor there's
two different kinds right so we could
have a back door that's inserted in
every single product that's shipped
so that seems to be what's hinted for
from that that budget document
is we spent money to weaken a specific
product in a way that everybody has that
weakness
um and then there are basically you know
what we would normally call root kits
but are much more complicated than root
kits
hardware back doors or system management
servers or firmware back doors
that are inserted into products on a
targeted basis um
so it's not surprising the nsa has
custom exploits and root kits
what is interesting is they have a huge
focus on physical access
um that they're doing the interdiction
of ship products um and that they have
firmware implants for lots of stuff so
they have juniper
hp basically any standard enterprise
product line in 2007 they had that
the products for so now they probably
even have a huge number more
um some more analysis here um
if you're gonna have a back door that's
in everything it's probably
indistinguishable from a real bug
right um so if you're looking for this
kind of stuff i would look for things
like timing leakage attacks
so there's been a lot of interesting
research in the public uh literature
over the last couple of years of looking
at timing of doing a crypto handshake
and what kind of stuff can you leak out
where some of these things might be a
little too
cute um bad pseudo-random number
generators
non-standard parameters and handshakes
so there are things that are standards
that are required
but in certain types of crypto
handshakes you have numbers that are
generated just for that one
and people use standard stuff like uh
you know to the 16 minus one and such
but if usually a non-standard thing that
might be an interesting hint
um and then if something's just an
exploit probably an obscure memory
management bug
right some kind of use after free bug
that requires a really
unlikely set of events to happen to set
memory up correctly before the exploit
happens
um so what do you do if you're a company
and you're worried about this so the
easiest thing is you don't buy products
that never touch the united states which
is
a very unfortunate outcome for americans
and for the american tech industry
if you are going to buy products from
the us uh then you probably want to buy
it from the channel
right so you don't want to you know
obviously the iranian government's not
calling up cisco and having stuff
dropshipped to them
right they're already buying it through
middlemen and such but
clearly there's probably a cat and mouse
game here where certain governments
are you know building shell companies
and such and then the us are figuring
out who their shell companies are
and then interdicting the shipments um
if you're really worried about this
then just buy your product from a place
where it's indistinguishable from a
bunch of them
right so if you go into a best buy and
you buy a laptop off the shelf it's
likely the nsa has not interdicted
and inserted a back door into that right
um
sorry no no off the website yes so if
you go to dell you tell them it's me the
one
in woodside if i want to get all the vc
information
the one he would sign yeah right um
this whole thing is interesting because
actually in the last five years uh the
government has told us in the private
industry you think a lot about our
supply chain security
and now what we know why they're talking
about that um because in the end
all this stuff flows through china right
so like an intel chip
is probably made in the us or in mexico
or in other places that intel tightly
controls
but then that package goes and gets put
on a motherboard with a bunch of other
stuff in china and then it's shipped to
a us manufacturer for final
you know it's if you look at the supply
chain for this product
there's probably 12 companies in the
world that you know could have a back
door in it right
i saw a guy i used to work with tim
newsham who's very smart said
maybe the only solution for this um is
that modern future computer
architectures
are almost completely flat where
everything's done in software and you
don't have
like this thing probably has 30 discrete
cpus right
you know do you know a thunderbolt cable
has a full arm processor in it
that was one of our talks at black hat
this summer is one of our guys put a
back door into the arm
into the thunderbolt chip to do a dma to
take control of your machine
over thunderbolt because the thunderbolt
cable you buy from intel has a full arm
core
in there um with that with a little
eeprom to pull its
operating system off
yeah and pci access yeah it's remoted
pcie so you can just do bus mastering
take over the whole thing
um and then be careful of prngs so a
great thing to back door would be a suit
a hardware sooner and number generator
there's some controversy on the linux
kernel list where now linux
this over the protests of linus torvalds
himself is now mixing in
some not as good entropy with the intel
rd rand instruction
um to to prevent this kind of stuff um
so some other stuff nsa likes to spy on
foreign leaders
the nsa likes to attack tor but they
don't have a magic bullet that was
interesting because tor uses
10 24-bit rsa in some situations um and
so there's a whole white paper on
attacking tor
that does not have a this is how we
magically unwrap tor um
but there are a bunch of attacks against
tor uh so if you think tor's gonna get
you
anywhere i would doubt it um nsa loves
to play with rf
um so this is the thing that was called
the thing
which was a bug that was implanted in a
seal of the united states
that was hand delivered to the american
ambassador to russia
by smiling singing russian school
children um literally
were sending a song and handed it over
to the russian ambassador to the u.s
ambassador
uh to decorate his office it turned out
embedded in it
was a microphone with a a long copper
antenna
that then uh so obviously they took that
and they're like great we're gonna go
put this in this faraday cage right now
and they go and they scan it and stuff
and it's not transmitting anything like
great well there's no bug
well turns out they didn't need to have
any active electronics because then they
beamed in a microwave
beam from the outside off this antenna
and then the vibrations from the sound
changed the antenna
louis thurman the guy who invented that
the crazy sound he's a
bulgarian i think he actually invented
this for the russians he worked on this
this product so it's uh
a really cool thing so the the modern
version of that is the nsa has
a vga cable where they have a tiny
little antenna attached to the red
line of the vga cable where you can
bounce an rf signal from outside on the
vga cable and then
recreate what's on somebody's screen for
that monitor which is a pretty good
upgrade
now this is interesting because um
there's some interesting memos
internally
uh where they're trying to estimate how
much radiation has been absorbed by the
people that worked in that office
and it's it's a non it's a somewhat
terrifying amount the russians weren't
that finely tuned
um or caring about the long-term
reproductive health of of the people who
work in the u.s embassy
in moscow i would guess it looks like
this is a much more targeted and tight
beam
um there's also exploitation of known
mobile weaknesses so
um we have three rogue base stations in
our office right so we have the ability
to interdict any gsm or cdma phone call
already so it's not a surprise that the
nsa has good off the shelf products to
do this
um so but uh you know they're doing a
lot of this
um interesting things we haven't seen
though no magic crypto
right so there's no no this is broken or
we have a backdoor to
this or don't use rsa none of that was
in any of these documents that we've
seen so far
um no quantum computers so nothing in
here indicates that the nsa has a
working quantum computer in fact there's
a document
that asks for money for development of a
quantum computer that doesn't mean they
don't have it somewhere
but um at least they're not admitting it
to in their black budget that they have
it
um uh and very little discussion of the
oday stuff i mean they talked about this
malware
but there's very little about how they
buy o days or what what their uh their
stockpile looks like
um so some general advice that we're
giving to companies um
you now need to include the nsa in your
list of thread actors right so when you
sit down you design a new system or new
data center or new office
um the nsa is a threat actor that
probably needs to be included
if you if you don't want to actually use
the term nsa in your documentation there
are
other things you can use but it does
make threat modeling a little more fun
again even if you're not worried about
the nsa specifically
we now know that all of these techniques
are doable
a lot of them you know like i said this
is something we can do
right uh our company so you know if you
if you
for the nsa stuff the stuff that doesn't
require submarines or huge amount of
physical access
most of that is probably available to
normal attackers
and so using that in your threat model
is probably going to help protect you
against lots of people that you're not
thinking about
if you're a business this is really a
business regulation issue so
you know lobbying the us government all
the major tech companies are doing that
they have a thing
a lobbying organization they've put
together specifically on the start on
this topic
um you need to start to prepare
transparency reports for non-us
regulators and consumers
which what you leave out is going to be
very carefully parsed so you got to be
careful what you're saying you don't say
um i added this slide for you guys
especially for the undergrads in the
room
who are going to be looking for jobs at
some point um
this is a very complicated issue the
ethics of a technologist
of whether or not we have you know some
people believe technologists are just
like
any other normal job that we have to you
know do our job and we have
kind of our external moral frameworks
but we don't have any special
responsibilities
other people think that we are somewhat
the technical priesthood of the 21st
century
and therefore have the same kind of
requirements that doctors put on
themselves
you know starting with the ancient
greeks and for years right so if you're
a us army doctor you are morally and
ethically illegally compelled
to provide services to your enemy right
so you have a co-worker who shoots
somebody
and then it's your job to make him not
die and that's the kind of like moral
imperative that medicine has
you know in the law um you know bradley
manning had a lawyer who's a military
lawyer
who was while bradley manning was being
prosecuted by u.s government for treason
or not exactly treason but something
like treason you know was ethically
obligated to provide him with the best
defense possible
right and that's our adversarial system
works and a lot of people think maybe
in the technology side we have some
built-in requirements that are universal
that are not just based upon the
you know specific world conundrum facing
us at that moment
um that's a very complicated issue i
gave a talk about a defcon
that you can find on youtube um it's a
it's a hard one
but i'm hoping that people think about
that if you're an undergrad you know
think about if you're going to work at a
company what your output's going to do
right um there's a certain company with
very nice offices on university avenue
um that you know their product is used
to spy on americans
even though they deny it but it is um
and uh
you know a lot of stanford grads go work
there and that's fine i don't think
that's immoral i think they're products
used for lots of non
uh immoral purpose a lot of moral
purposes um
but you need to think very closely about
your work product what kind of
effect you want to have on the world i
don't think you can just ignore it and
cash the check
yeah i'm not going to say the name of
any company um
you just seem you seem wise enough uh to
make your own decision sir
um so with the future uh we'll probably
see more snowden's
um there's an interesting race for
quantum computing uh in all this kind of
stuff it it seems like the race is on
and
it hasn't been won yet um and uh
equivalent data gathering abilities
actually in the hands of many many
private companies
uh you know people who host dns handset
makers and such so
uh again the attack scenarios here are
not just based uh
you know around the us government great
thank you
you